we both did that sam adams deal man that
was because of you
yeah it was cool i wasn't even supposed
to be on that thing that was until the
deal called
i'm glad i did it was that yours was
really cute man pio theo is amazing
i want everyone to know that i thought
yours was cool man let's watch it real
quick
telling jokes for a living this is my
dream come true
i always wanted to be a comic and i love
it
i'm joe coy stand-up comedian
and i'm here to toast my mother that
tupac baby
harrison without her none of this would
have happened
i think a lot of people forget to just
be grateful
people do stuff for us and then we just
act as if that's what they were supposed
to do yeah it also sucks when you help
somebody and they walk by and you're
like
sort of a [ __ ] didn't even thank me
ungrateful [ __ ]
my mom sacrificed everything to give me
the opportunity to live my dream
and this coast was the best opportunity
for me to say thank you
you know when my mom and dad divorced i
was right around 10 11
and she became everything she was pretty
much the backbone of the entire family
when i said i want to be a comic her
head was like
you crazy is it your house i remember
working in a shower storage still doing
stand up at night my mom was just like
i told you stop doing this you're going
to be broke
no we live in a country where dreams are
possible and it can happen
just give me some time
since day one i wanted to make sure that
the world
could laugh and when i tell your story
on stage
it's something that i'm very proud of
for years i was like how am i going to
talk about my mom
i didn't want to go up on stage and just
be like oh i'm filipino and filipinos do
this
if you listen you're going to be like oh
my mom does the same [ __ ] i mean you're
doing great and i'm
proud of you you wanted me to be a
lawyer well we digress
now i see being a comedian my goodness i
mean you're
one thousand percent secure sam adams
it's grassroots it's family what i take
from that
is the same thing that i got for my mom
and that's why sam adams is the best
beer for this toast the reason why i
brought you here today is i wanted to
toast you
this is hard harder than i thought
pretty lady man
it's a little too much you came to this
country was to give the kids an
opportunity that
you knew that you would never have
everywhere i go people will be yelling
your name
and they grab their hand and i know it's
because of you
honestly so i also want you to know that
i'm so proud of you
you see you started this you're the
reason why i've been able to do this
thank you for everything you sacrificed
so this is for you and i love you
did your mom drink beer i toast you ah
you got me all right
so much thank you oh i always cry in
here
that's good yeah it's good i love it
it's cool
too you want some more yeah
you want some more
that's why i i didn't plan on watching
it all the way through but it's nice
it's a nice sentiment man you know it's
important oh man
it's you know it's hard to have like
moments like that with our parents i
think
it's hard to get to those moments and
then actually follow through and
actually have them
yeah like sometimes i'll have an idea in
my head like okay i want to talk to my
mom about this or say this
or you know tell a family member this
but when it comes down to the moment
i just don't really follow through the
way i want to
i'll back off at a moment when i have a
feeling of some sort that's
uncomfortable
yeah you're right it's weird man it is
weird
but it's important you know it's
important bro that was cool
i didn't know he was crying i was trying
to fight my there was
did you see me nick do this i looked out
like ah man not now
she's pretty lady man dude uh dude did
you hear what she said
uh that's that's when you know i'm not
lying about
my mom when she goes uh when i knew you
were a thousand percent secure oh
that those were those conversations when
she would tell me to quit
yeah secure that's a unique word people
don't just throw that around a lot of
times
yeah she she was all about benefits and
health insurance
security retirement like dude like
that's military stuff yeah man
that's my mom that's how she talk you
know she was married to
two soldiers so that's all she talks
about my mom's been talking about
retirement since
she was 36.
so you just live first talk about
retirement later
that's funny man yeah it's powerful man
it's interesting man it's interesting to
see
now thanks for uh calling uh those guys
by the way that was really cool of you
yeah that was great well they had a cool
campaign man mm-hmm
it was a cool campaign you did yours
with i did mine just with the audience
oh yeah so mine was just at the laugh
factory with the audience
brendan did his i think with brian yeah
who else segura
shafir oh how was saguras i didn't see
that one
um he might have done his wife
oh yeah probably yeah i gotta watch it
but pretty cool man good evening good
afternoon
and other times thanks for watching that
video you just saw
i mean it was okay but the next video
you can watch
could be way better what if you watch a
video right now that changes
your life well you could watch this one
or watch this one
watch this one watch this one watch this
one
ah